Aujourd'hui, je vous parle d'un plat
qu'on adore déguster en famille
ou entre amis,
quand il fait froid comme aujourd'hui.
Encore plus quand il y a de la neige
ou qu'on est à la montagne.
Les ingrédients de base de la charcuterie,
des pommes de terre, des cornichons
et bien sûr, du fromage.
Vous avez deviné ?
La raclette.
Qui l'a inventée ?
Les Français ?
Les Suisses ?
Quel est le meilleur fromage à raclette ?
Direction l'atelier.
Je vous raconte l'histoire secrète de la raclette.
Il fait pas chaud.
On va se régaler.
Il y a 1 chance sur 2 que vous aimiez la raclette.
En effet, d'après les chiffres,
la moitié des foyers français en consomme chaque hiver.
En moyenne, 3 fois dans la saison.
Une moitié qui aime et une moitié qui n'aime pas.
Ils ont fondu les plombs.
Bon, pour ceux qui n'aiment pas,
vous pouvez quand même rester
car vous allez le voir, l'histoire de ce plat est étonnante.
Faire fondre du fromage
près d'une source de chaleur,
c'est une idée qui ne date pas d'hier.
Dans les Alpes françaises,
beaucoup de paysans
avaient l'habitude
de faire rôtir du fromage au coin du feu.
Mais la raclette,
celle que nous connaissons aujourd'hui,
nous vient du Valais,
un canton du sud de la Suisse.
Son origine remonterait au Moyen Âge.
Une légende raconte
qu'après avoir rentré leurs troupeaux,
des bergers
se seraient rassemblés autour du feu.
Grelottant de froid, ils auraient décidé
de faire fondre le fromage
sur des pierres disposées autour du feu,
alors qu'ils avaient l'habitude
de le manger froid.
Et ils l'auraient mangé
chaud pour se réchauffer.
Cette technique de cuisson est mentionnée pour la première fois
à la fin du XVIᵉ siècle, dans les notes
d'un médecin suisse de la ville de Sion.
Il décrit le plat avec des mots très élogieux.
Il le dit savoureux, gras, doux et tendre à l’âpre saveur.
Hmmm, ça donne envie.
Traditionnellement, les paysans utilisaient un fromage
à base de lait cru de vache à pâte mi-dure
qu'on appelle tout simplement le Valais,
du nom du canton dans lequel il est produit.
A l'époque, on faisait toujours fondre
le fromage dans la cheminée.
Les montagnards le faisaient ensuite couler sur des pommes de terre
en raclant à l'aide d'une spatule ou d'un couteau.
D'où le nom raclette, qui n'apparaît
officiellement
qu'en 1874,
mais il ne désigne à l'époque que le fromage.
Ce n'est qu'en 1909 que le terme raclette
finit par désigner le plat entier.
On le doit à un certain Oscar Perollaz,
qui, à l'occasion de l'exposition
cantonale Valaisienne,
a composé avec son épouse Marguerite,
une chanson intitulée "La raclette".
Je vous en cite quelques vers :
“Blonde raclette, en gouttelettes,
sous l'étincelle, quand la dentelle
on l’assaisonne, on la dit bonne,
sur nos assiettes, en gouttelettes”.
Le tube de l'hiver ?
Eh bien non, justement.
Car autrefois,
la saison de la raclette, c'était l'été.
La fête de la raclette avait lieu mi-août,
lorsque les fromages
étaient arrivés à maturité.
Les producteurs y présentaient leur fromage,
qui était même béni
par le curé de la paroisse.
Mais n'imaginez pas
qu'on se mettait
autour d'une bonne raclette pour un oui ou pour un non.
Elle était réservée
aux jours de fêtes et aux grandes occasions.
Au fil du temps,
les visiteurs de passage dans le Valais découvrent ce plat,
certes un peu lourd, mais délicieux.
Petit à petit, la raclette envahit
les tables des milieux aisés.
Mais aussi surprenant
que cela puisse paraître,
il a fallu de longues années à la raclette
pour conquérir la France.
Elle ne passe la frontière suisse qu'en 1973.
Cette année là, le commercial d'une célèbre marque de fromage
découvre la raclette et il comprend très vite
le parti que son entreprise peut en tirer, de l'autre côté des Alpes.
Il lance donc la production du célèbre fromage dans l'Hexagone.
Puis il teste le plat dans les stations de ski, alors en plein essor.
Et ça marche.
Le succès est tel qu'en 1978,
le premier appareil individuel à 6 poêlons,
celui que nous connaissons
tous, sort sur le marché.
Son succès est immédiat.
Mais ce n'était pas gagné,
car cet appareil n'a rien de rustique.
En revanche, il est très pratique.
Plus besoin
d'acheter une demi-meule de fromage
ou d'aller au restaurant
pour déguster une raclette.
En plus, il est très convivial et en quelques
temps, l'appareil devient le cadeau idéal
à offrir pour les anniversaires
ou les mariages.
Bon, maintenant,
passons aux choses sérieuses.
Une bonne raclette, ça vous dit ?
Alors, direction les cuisines.
C'est par là.
Pour la réussir, il faut
commencer par choisir de bons produits.
Et pour commencer, de la bonne charcuterie.
Jambon sec, rosette, viande des Grisons.
Vous pouvez même ajouter
du jambon de Paris si le cœur vous en dit.
En fait, la palette est extrêmement large.
Le gros avantage avec la raclette,
c'est que vous pouvez
l'adapter aux goûts de chacun.
Tenez, si vous êtes végétarien,
par exemple,
vous pouvez parfaitement remplacer
la charcuterie par des légumes grillés,
des poivrons
par exemple,
des brocolis, du chou fleur, des champignons.
Ils se marient très bien
avec le fromage fondu.
Ensuite, il faut choisir les pommes de terre.
Des pommes de terre à chair ferme
comme l’Amandine ou la Charlotte.
Elles tiennent mieux lors de la cuisson
et ne s'effritent pas
au premier coup de couteau.
Petit conseil
ne retirez pas la peau pour les faire cuire.
Vous perdez jusqu'à 90% des vitamines.
Une fois cuites,
vous les disposez dans un plat
qui ne craint pas la chaleur en ajoutant
un petit peu d'eau au fond.
Lorsque notre appareil à raclette sera chaud,
nous poserons le plat dessus.
Ça évitera de manger des patates froides.
Pour finir, le plus important, bien sûr,
le fromage.
Alors, pour faire une raclette
dans les règles de l'art,
il faut utiliser le fromage
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure.
Le raclette du Valais,
c'est une appellation d'origine protégée.
Il s'agit d'un fromage à pâte mi-dure,
je l'ai dit,
produit à base de lait
cru de vache, affiné 3 à 6 mois.
Les Tomme du Valais font en moyenne
6 kilogrammes
et sont parfois fumés ou agrémentés de poivre
ou d'herbes,
ce qui leur donne un arôme à la fois
corsé et fleuri.
Bon, autant vous le dire tout de suite,
ce n'est pas facile à dénicher.
J'ai fait 4 fromageries
et j'en ai pas trouvé.
On ne va pas en faire tout un fromage.
Non, ça marche aussi très bien
avec de la raclette de Savoie,
qu'elle soit nature, fumée ou au poivre.
On peut aussi utiliser
du morbier ou de l'abondance,
c'est délicieux.
L'important, c'est que votre fromage
ait du goût
et soit onctueux pour fondre correctement.
Et pour ça, mieux vaut en acheter moins, mais
du bon, en privilégiant
les produits de votre fromager.
Voilà, je crois qu'il ne manque rien.
C'est presque prêt.
L'avantage avec la raclette et moi j'aime ça,
c'est qu'elle demande pas trop de boulot
à celui qui la prépare.
C'est vrai qu'une fois les produits achetés
et les pommes de terre cuites,
c'est l'appareil qui fait tout le travail.
Du coup, si vous aimez la variété,
mieux vaut utiliser un appareil
à raclette classique,
un appareil à poêlons.
Ça, c'est le mien.
Un appareil tout à fait classique.
Bon, il a un peu vécu et il est composé
d'une résistance, d'un plateau
juste au dessus qui permet
de réverbérer la chaleur
et de poser les pommes de terre
pour les tenir au chaud.
Et puis, bien sûr, des petits poêlons.
Allez, c'est parti !
Allez, chauffe Marcel !
Si, comme moi, vous raffolez de la raclette,
pourquoi pas vous inscrire à la Raclette
Cup ?
Elle est organisée chaque année
par des étudiants de Chambéry, en Savoie.
En 2021, ils ont établi un record.
Plus de 1000 d'entre eux se sont partagés
une raclette géante,
110 appareils à raclette,
400 kilos de pommes de terre, 410 kilos de fromage,
et 9000 tranches de charcuterie.
Je crois que c’est bon.
Pour patienter,
j'ai une petite devinette pour vous.
Savez-vous qui détient le record
de la plus grosse meule
de fromage à raclette ?
Vous avez une petite idée ?
Eh oui, sans surprise, ce sont des Suisses.
En 2004, ils ont réalisé
une meule de, tenez vous bien,
135 kilogrammes.
Ça fait un fromage d'1m23 de diamètre.
Cela représente 2000 tranches de fromage.
De quoi passer une bonne soirée raclette.
Hmmm...
C'est bon !
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Si elle vous a mis en appétit, n'hésitez
pas à liker et à vous abonner à la chaîne.
Et puis, si vous vous posez des questions
sur certains plats
ou certains aliments,
inscrivez-les en commentaire.
Je me ferai un plaisir d'y répondre
dans une prochaine vidéo Sur la planche.
Tenez, il y a quelques semaines, par exemple,
j'en ai fait une sur les frites.
Allez voir, ça va vous plaire.
Allez, à très bientôt
sur la chaîne des
Épicurieux, et régalez-vous.